all right so in this video i want to
share a game which i played against
hikaru nakamura this was a title tuesday
i think it was a title tuesday right
before the candidates began and the game
is really cool it features a london
opening that hikaru played he doesn't
usually play the london but i think he
just wanted to try and beat me with my
own opening
and i responded with a really topical
and interesting gambit against london
led to a really fun game and i think
there's lots of lessons to take away so
enjoy the video
and stay tuned for more content playing
karu
i usually play down in round two but i'm
playing akaru
okay uh and i'm black
what to do
[Music]
when is your host tv tournament
um i can't answer that right now i'm
muting chat i have to focus
what's the sakaru play he's gonna play
knight too
i'll probably play takes in this line
yeah bishop b5 is coming
oh he's playing more positional
so queen b3 knight here or bishop here
um
i looked at this a while ago i don't
think this is super venomous but
i am playing akaru
so if i play
if i play bishop d6 here
we trade
it's so important to just not overthink
things
all right stocked upon
it looks playable 94.
remember some knight e4 g5 g4
also remember that rook b1 comes at some
point
i think rook b1 or rook b8 immediately
and then knight e4
and this is prep i looked at like over
six months ago
i was helping a friend during us champs
okay so the problem is if i play g5
there's takes takes
so there's 96
and then
g3 so maybe like rook b6 and then g5
like i don't remember exact prep but i
remember ideas
okay i didn't miss knight c3 because
bishop does defend the rook maybe i
should have played rook b6 sooner
not sure
like right after rook b1
you're doing okay time wise
this is hard to stop actually
caro goes pawn grabbing
so g4
i mean
gotta go for it
takes quinji now queen g5 almost kinda
works but it doesn't
hmm
the problem is i have to prove something
here
bishop d2
and there's rook wait he's writing media
one oh man almost missed it
he's ready made in one
takes knight c5
i'm down two pawns but uh
i can't freak out like 97
27.88
stop hurting me i have to play king g8
at some point
time is not good anymore
that's still interesting though
the knight's unpinned
thank you g cook
pawn is a little bit tender
please castle
[Music]
like d3 ideas
queen d4
i want to make rook h2 work
still some pressure
yeah
advantages or my compensation is fading
just like my hopes and dreams
in this move
d4
it doesn't work though
i have no time
[Music]
i could try to set up the stalemate
trick
but that requires sagging all my pawns
this that's not even a threat
okay c3 is backwards
that was my slip
um
go my rook
go my time
oh hecaro outplayed me
it was a very tense position i spent a
lot of time in the
like early middle game trying to
how do i click on moves
trying to figure out
the
complications
um
yeah we played some
variation of
a different line
because
the main line that i've studied is queen
b3 bishop d6 queen takes takes
takes king f8
but
he included knight h4n g6 which
maybe favors white
it was interesting though
like very double-edged position
yeah this is already like pretty uh
lesser played line
engine
so engine gives close to equal
apparently i should have played g5
oh i should have played g5 sooner
that makes a lot of sense
yeah i ended up losing two pawns
and then
but the engine says it's equal wow oh i
had g3
now it says g3 is losing
oh sockfish being savage
so apparently g3 bishop takes e4 if i
take on h2
rook f1 and black doesn't have anything
oh there's still chances though so queen
c7 ah defending attacking
and if queen here the queen supports
rook b8
so that would have offered me slightly
better chances
but
it seems i was never better than this
game
like i definitely have improvements but
i was never actually better okay
what to do